[Music]
welcome to the quick start tutorial for
workflows
in this video we're going to walk
through how to get started with
workflows
which allows you to create serverless
workflows that reliably perform
a series of related tasks in an order
you define
to start make sure you have a google
cloud project set up in the google cloud
platform console with billing enabled
you can either create a new project or
use an existing project
next enable the workflows api in the
navigation menu
click on apis and services click the
enable apis and services button at the
top
search for workflows and select it from
the results
on the workflows api page click enable
to enable it for the project
set up a service account to grant
permissions needed by your workflow to
call services
in the navigation menu click on iam and
admin
service accounts
click create service account at the top
give your service account a name and
click create
give your service account the role of
logging
logs writer click continue
and then done
navigate to the workflows page in the
cloud console
it will be one of the options in the
tools section
on the workflows page click create
provide a name for the workflow such as
my first
workflow
select uscentral1 for the region and
select the service account you created
earlier for service account
click next in the workflow editor
we're going to use the example workflow
this workflow fetches the current date
and time from a deployed cloud function
it then takes the current day of the
week and sends it to the wikipedia api
to fetch relevant articles on wikipedia
about the current day of the week
click deploy
now that your workflow has been
successfully deployed you can go ahead
and test it out
after deploying the workflow you are
brought to its details page
click the execute button at the top and
then click execute
this will execute your new workflow and
print out the final results at the
bottom
you can see that some wikipedia articles
related to today's day of the week
include thursday night football and
thursday afternoon
as you can see workflows allows you to
connect apis with serverless computing
you can also use workflows to connect
custom services built on products like
cloud functions and cloud run
gcp services such as cloud firestore and
any apis available on the internet
and that's it congratulations on
creating deploying
and executing your first workflow make
sure to check out the rest of our
workflows documentation to learn more
you